,
Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair.
(klaxons)
- Certains ont priououououte
depuis quelques jours déjà.
Venu du Nord, du Sud ou de
l'Ouest, ils forment différents
convois. Beaucoup de voitures
et de camionnettes muuuu
de poids lourds, contrairement
au Canada. Pour beaucoup
de manifestants, la demande est
claire ils exigent la fin
des restrictions sanit
- Avec le pass vaccinal, là,
on ne peut plus aller où on
veut, on ne peut plus faire ce
qu'on veut. Donc il est temps
que nous rendent nos lib
- Le mouvement n'a pas
d'organisation définie.
Certains manifestants militent
pour un meilleur pouvoir
d'achat, un enjeu qui étai
au coeur des revendications
des gilets jaunes.
- Regardons la réalité, le prix
de l'énergie, tout ça se passei.
- Peu importe lesvevevevevendicn
est la même: Paris.
Si certains sympathisants
leur avaient préparé un comité
d'accueil dans le sud de la
capitale, atteindre la ville
n'est pas évident. Les entrées
de la région parisienne sont
surveillées. Les autor
veulent empêcher ce convoi
qu'elles estiment à quelques
milliers de véhicules peut créer
des perturbations.
TETETETETEX
premier ministre de la France
- Le droit de manifester et
d'avoir une opinion est un droit
constitutionnellement garanti
dans notre république et dans
notre démocratie. Le droit de
bloquer les autres ou d'empêcher
d'aller et venir ne l'est pas.
- La préfecture de police
de Paris a interdit ce type
de rassemblement à bord
de véhicules pour la fin de
semaine. Entraver la circulation
est notamment e e e e e e 4500
euros d'amende et d'une peine
d'emprisonnement. Question
d'accentuer la dissuasion,
plus de 7000 policiers ont étéot
véhicules blindés sont bien
visibles. Comme ici, près
des Champs-Élysées.
Si le gouvernement envoie
un message de fermeté, il a
aussi annoncé la levée prochaine
de certaines mesures sanitaires
qui sont visées par les
contestations. À la fin du mois,
le port du masque ne sera plus
obligatoire dans les l
soumis au passeport vaccinal.
Les autorités évoquent même
une possible levée de la
vérification du statut vaccinal
p p p p p p prochains mois.
Une grogne palpable,
des services policiers en
alerte. Les risques de
débordement sont présents.
Dans un journal, le président
Emmanuel Macron a lancé un appel
au calme, question d'éviter
un regain de tension, à deux
mois du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle.
Ici RaphaeAuAuAuAuAuAuAuclair,
Radio-Canada, Paris